Yasmine is with us now hi Yasmin talk to
us about your situation
um well essentially my grandfather who
is a British national has been stuck in
Sudan over the past 10 days of fighting
we lost contact with them last Monday
after hearing that the house was raided
by 15 soldiers taking all their food all
their water they have had no electricity
for the past 10 days
um so obviously their phones run out of
battery we've been on the phone to the
British Embassy
at least 10 times a day every single day
looking for help looking for answers
looking for some sort of development in
if there's an evacuation plan and we
have had not one single bit of help
do you know where they are now
we have no idea we hope that they're
safe inside the house there's no reason
to believe that they would want to leave
because it's as dangerous outside as it
is indoors but the more the days go on
the more we think to ourselves how well
can they be my granddad is 89 my
grandmother is 75. no food or water for
a week
no way of getting in no way of getting
out what makes it even worse is that
they very very funnily enough live on
the exact same block as the British
Embassy
we have been contacting them by all
platforms we can Twitter phone Facebook
Instagram trying to tell them that they
are located less than a minute walk from
the British Embassy even if there is no
evacuation plan in place for British
Nationals the least they could have done
is taken some water some food to their
front door to ensure that they could
survive another few days had they done
that not at all
next thing we know all British diplomats
and Embassy workers have evacuated now
they've changed their tune to they want
a ceasefire we've been asking for
ceasefire for nine days now it has not
carried out for one single hour
what is the answer
what can we possibly do to the thousands
of British Nationals that are stranded
not even stranded they've been left
behind and now there's absolutely no
news of getting them out there's no plan
in place why is it that so many other
countries took their diplomats
understandably because apparently they
were under more threat they took their
diplomats and now they're putting into
place plans to evacuate their Nationals
why aren't the British government doing
the same thing
yeah what's your message to the British
government
um this morning Yasmin
my message is put a plan in place and
let people know don't live don't leave
your National stranded in a foreign
country in the same way that you look
after your Nationals at home look after
them abroad why is it that one human's
life is more
important than another human's life it
makes absolutely no sense
thank you for taking the time to join us
um I know that daily watches in number
10 and hopefully
um your grandparents will be safe and
sound before too long do let us know
when you do manage to get in touch with
them we have everything crossed for you
thank you thank you so much